welcome to today's live broadcast
targeted single cell rna sequencing
enables genome scale crispr screens
i am jen woods of lab roots and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by illumina and bd biosciences
for more information about our sponsors
please visit
illumina.com and bdbiosciences.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click the send button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenters
dr kyle hulse
dr zajac and dr burke summer
for a complete biography on our
presenters please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen dr kyle
holes you may now begin your
presentation
thanks a lot jen for the kind
introduction and it is my honor now
to start this this webinar today
on christmas screens and i would like to
briefly introduce the bd rhapsody single
cell analysis system
powering biological research i hope you
can all see my screen
okay and um with this i would like to go
to the first slide
with a little bit of an introduction on
bd biosciences so
bd biosciences is active and is
supporting biological research
on on the single cell level for over 40
years now
with the invention of the facts
technology and the first facts
cytometers coming to life in 1974
and since then we have developed as a
company
as the market leader really in flow
cytometry
with nowadays over 9000 instruments
installed just across europe and um
over 92 of citations in flow cytometry
instrument citations
we now um being a marketing leader is
nice
but the challenge really stays in
staying a market market leader and
this requires what we are actually doing
we are having
an increasing portfolio of reagents and
instruments and keep on further
developing this for now um we have more
than 20 000 flow cytometry reagents
on our catalog we have the bd horizon
brilliant
dies we have the bd opti builds on
demand portfolio custom reagents
and the bd1 flow solution for diagnostic
testing as well
that's on the reagent side certainly the
keeps investing in innovative
instrumentations and we have a whole
portfolio of instruments and um
ever keep uh increasing the um the the
the platforms here and one platform i
would like to talk about
today very briefly which is the bd
rhapsody system
however as as all of media biosciences
we really want to
be and stay your partner of choice
when it comes to scientific solutions
and this is supported
by powerful and intuitive software
solutions and tools that we are offering
but last not least our
very skilled teams of field applications
technical support
who are helping you in your labs
with your biological research
now i would like to briefly introduce
the bd rhapsody
system to you and just show the workflow
components here
on the left hand side you see the video
rhapsody scanner
below the scanner you see an electronic
pipet which belongs to the system
and then we also have the big reps of
the express
the cartridge station now the core of
this technology
really is the bd rhapsody cartridge
which you can see on the right hand side
and in order to explain a little bit
more what is happening here
i will advance to the next slide
on the left hand side you see the
microworld cartridge and this is
actually
already saying what it is it is a
cartridge made of microwaves and as you
can see in this little insert
um these hexagonal tape of microwells we
have more than 200 000 of those
on the cartridge and the idea is to load
the cell
solution or the cell dispensing into
your cartridge
let the cell settle down into the
microwave and individualize
them by this process all of this
in the lab is supported by the bd
rhapsody express station that you can
see in the middle here
and this is actually a very small tool a
very
very um not complicated tool
it doesn't even need electrical power
you can easily put it under the
under the hood and manipulate the
cartridge
with the help of this little device
below here
you see the workflow what is happening
on the cartridge
the idea is you load your cells and the
beads
and you can see in this little insert
down here there is a one of these
hexagonal
shaped um microwells sitting
in red there's a or in orange there's a
bead sitting in there
and in blue there is a cell sitting in
there that's that's the idea of of the
system
coupling cells that in one cell with one
beat
this is how you achieve the resolution
on the single cell
um next step in this workflow you would
lyse the cells
as you can see hopefully here the cell
in blue is sort of melting away
and the the yellow no not yellow the
orange lead now has a coating in blue
which um reflects the analytic molecules
that are captured by the speed
which is is mrna and um potentially also
tagged from antibodies i will come to
this a little later
what also happens then is you will
retrieve the beads the beads are
magnetic and the
magnet is applied from the top of the
cartridge and this is happening in the
express station
and then collect all the beads into a
single
vial or into a single ependorf tube and
where you then do the downstream
chemistry in the lab so you synthesize
the dna
and the cdna and after
creating a library for an extended
sequencing in
in the end then you analyze the data
now what is the scanner for the scanner
is an imaging tool
and it is used in quality control
as you can see on the top of this of
this slide here this is the workflow
you start with the cell count cell
variability check we'll sell the meat
capture
light speed retrieval that library prep
as i said before and
on the right hand side we belong or
um we go to an illumina system and do a
next-gen sequence in readout all of this
uh experiment is valuable and costly and
we want to get as
much control over it as possible and
this is where we use the scanner for
we use the scanner actually already for
cell count and cell variability testing
which is not seen on the slide here but
um i put down
the um the steps cell bead and bead
capture
and the lysis and bead retrieval and as
you can see here
are some real images on the in in
the uh on the left hand side of these
images you see
a cell sitting in the in the microwelds
and
um i've circled them in orange for
better visibility
so these are individual cells and you
see that this
cartridge is heavily under loaded the
reason for this is
um we want individual cells to be
sitting in there
and not multiplex that is two or more
cells
per well
in the middle we have applied the beads
and as you see we overload the cartridge
now we have many more beads in there
than needed but the
idea is to have one bead per microwell
um there is no space for two beads to be
put in there so we are we are happy that
we are safe on this side
what i do not have here is uh we wash
away the excess beads
um this is a picture which we also
acquire by the
scanner which i just simply don't show
here um on the right hand side then we
see
after retrieval of the bees we want to
make make sure that the cartridge indeed
is empty
and as you can see this is the case so
by by using the scanner you have a full
control over the entire workflow
and that means you are not running uh
like like in a
black box
certainly we really want to be nice to
ourselves this is about
transcriptome assessment and
transcriptome analysis and you all know
that
cells keep keep
adjusting their behavior based on what
they see from the outside
so in other words if you apply stress to
the cell the cell will
change its transcriptome towards
stress-related genes and
express them more strongly this
certainly is what we don't want
and please keep in mind that all of all
of
us all of our cells all cells on earth
for their whole lifespan are exposed to
gravity so gravity is something that is
really normal to every single cell
the buffer system that we are using the
cells
or that we put the cells in is a
physiological buffer
so cells in the physiological buffer are
most likely
quite happy and then we are using
gravity
to individualize them as i as i said
before the the cells
just slowly sink into the microworlds
without
putting any pressure on them so this is
as physiological as we can be
and as you can see here down down in the
graph
what we did we we compared the rhapsody
outcome to flow cytometry which is still
seen as a or which is seen as a gold
standard
the orange bars are flow cytometry data
on the x-axis we have different cell
types of a composition of cells
on the y-axis we have the percent of
life cells in that
um that's that's sampled
and this is based on two different
replicas from two different mice and as
you as you can see
um very roughly flow data and rhapsody
run
number one in blue and reps of the num
number two in gray
is pretty much in the same range so
um this proves that we really also on
the rhapsody
see what we would see on a flow
instrument
and on the right what the media rhapsody
we can currently load and process about
40 000
cells in one go on one cartridge
so this is what we currently have to
offer on the left hand side the
instrument
of course and we can address cells and
nuclei
in the middle we you see the assays that
we are currently offering which is a
whole
transcriptome amplification essay i
would say three prime biased
um the targeted rna-seq essay which we
are going to hear a lot more about today
and the sample multiplexing kit vdj
immune repertoire testing and appseek
i'm not going to talk about these today
on the right hand side all of this is
supported by
bioinformatics tools that make your life
hopefully easier because they should be
easy to use
now this is an animated slide and this
is almost my final slide here
so the bd1 solution really is
we have a discovery workflow starting
from the left hand side here with blood
and tissue
or cell culture that you can put into
the bd rhapsody system you have a
heterogeneous cell population here
you can apply sorting for enrichment by
using a flux
sorter and then of course the discovery
part comes where the bdd rhapsody is
really positioned
and then the computational analysis
which is also known as the
as a primary analysis and then certainly
on the informatics side as i said before
bd has some solutions to help you with
um
good um with generating or
visualizing your your data
and with this i'm coming to to the end
of my presentation of my
short presentation today on the media
rhapsody system and i will be more than
happy to
hand over now to pavel from illumina
thanks a lot
all right so thank you very much
vlan for this really nice introduction
about single cell sequencing and
the bd rhapsody system and of course
thank you very much to all of you for
joining us at this
exciting webinar and as mentioned my
name is
pavel sayak i'm part of illumina's
marketing team and it's my great
pleasure to
in the next five minutes or so present
illumina to you who we are what we do
and also tell you a little bit
a little bit about our latest sequencing
news
so for those of you who haven't heard
about illumina we are a global company
and we develop manufacture and market
innovative next generation sequencing
and microarray technologies
and our technology enables you to make
foundational discoveries to transform
medicine
and ultimately to impact lives
and to date there are more than 200 000
publications where our technology has
been used so it clearly shows that this
is a robust technology
that you can trust and there are two
ways in which you can get access to our
technology
you can either purchase a system and
implement it in-house
in your own lab but you can also turn to
one of the many service
providers and get access to our
technology
through these service providers
so we do provide next generation
sequencing systems
and it is a single technology but it
unlocks a range of applications
and a range of biological insights
so the sequencer can be seen as a tool
and by preparing the sample in different
ways you can use this
tool the sequencer to get access to a
multitude of biological
insights so if you take a look at for
example cancer research of course you
can
use our sequencing systems to do single
cell sequencing
but you can also perform tumor mutation
profiling for instance via whole genome
sequencing or exome sequencing
to figure out what differentiates the
the
the tumor from normal tissue
and you can also do for example 16
sequencing or shotgun
metagenomics to figure out what is the
microbial component and how does
the microbial component affect the tumor
in our sequencing systems they enable a
wide range of
single cell applications so no matter
which biological modality you're
interested in whether that's
rna or dna or protein or different
regulatory features
and no matter if you want to do a global
analysis or you want to
zoom in on a targeted set of for example
transcripts
we do have sequencing solutions that fit
your output needs
and it's exactly the same with your
study size
so irrespective of if you have a small
study or a large study we are more than
happy to
assist you with the sequencing part
and we have a nice portfolio of of
sequencing systems
uh at the bottom left hand side of the
slide you can see our iseq 100 system
that's our smallest most affordable
benchtop system giving you 4 million
reads and on the right hand side
we do have our nova 6000 system which is
our production scale sequence for those
larger studies and earlier this year we
launched our nexiq 2000 platform
which allows for deep and large studies
but still within
a benchtop package
so there are a number of technological
innovations that have gone into making
the nexic 2000
and it clearly shows our long-standing
tradition of technological
innovation and all these technological
innovations they translate into a number
of
significant advantages so for example
there is a reduction in operating cost
and the
the reagent kit size compared to the
nexsiq 550
and also the output is increased from
400 million reads that you get with the
next 550 to 1 billion reads that you get
with the next c2000
so paving the way for those larger and
deeper and broader
singles and sequencing studies
and just a couple of months ago we also
released
the latest version of the consumables
for our
novaseq 6000 system so our production
scale sequencer
and these consumables carry a number of
advantages as well
and one is a attractive price point
meaning that you can sequence
more within the same sequencing budget
so this once again opens the door for
those larger
broader and deeper single cell
sequencing studies allowing you to
see more of what's happening in your
biological samples
in addition to the the the price change
the new consumers also have a number of
additional advantages such as greater
flexibility improved robustness and
enhanced user experience
to name one example the shelf life has
been increased from three months to
six months and if you have any questions
about
any of our solutions maybe you are
considering a project and
and you're interested in discussing
different options please don't hesitate
to to reach out we are more than happy
to assist
so with this i very much wanted to thank
you for
for your attention and i will now have
turned the presentation to
to tillman the the star of today please
take it away tillman
excellent thank you pabl
just a moment
okay can you see my
slide
so um
thanks again for the very nice
introduction um
into the bd rhapsody system um vland and
and thanks for introducing us to
the illumina product portfolio
my name is tillman berkshimmer and i'm
the chief scientist of alien
biotechnology
based in vienna and austria and the
title of my talk today
is targeted single cell rna sequencing
enables genome scale crystal screens
now i have to quickly show this
disclaimer slide
before going into
the introductory slide so at alien we
run crisper screens crisper screens rely
on the crispr cast 9 system which can be
used
to disrupt any gene of interest
and the main application of the
technology to date
at least with clients in industry is
target
discovery and target validation so a lot
of the
drug discovery programs start these days
start with the crisper screen
and so the way a crisper screen works is
when we start
with a population of cells in which
we introduce the cast iron endonuclease
together with the library of guide rnas
and now this library of guide rnas will
establish
a population of gene knockouts
and then we have two screening paradigms
one
is the positive selection screen where
some clones like the ones shown here in
red become more dominant
on the other hand we have a negative
selection
scheme where certain clones disappear in
the experiment
now what are the readouts that are
currently used for crisper screens
the simplest readout that you can think
of is a fitness screen
where for instance you might start off
with this population of gene knockouts
and tree
cells with a drug and in the course of
the experiment some of the gene
knockouts as a consequence of the drug
treatment will become more or less
dominant
the advantage of those screens is that
they're very scalable people have done
them
in fact a genome scale but in an ideal
world
you would like to be able to address
more complex biological questions
and so there is a nice middle ground
here which
is the crispr screens that are based on
flow cytometry
they exploit cell surface markers which
we can stain with
fluorescent antibodies or intracellular
reporters
but what you would really like to be
able to do is perturb
a set of genes in a given cell and then
read out essentially
all the changes as they happen as a
consequence of the gene knockout
so this is a multi-parametric screen
um but of course that
is sort of a more difficult undertaking
and we think
single cell rna sequencing is a very
interesting
approach for those types of screens
so alien our typical workflow um starts
off
with a cas9 expressing cell line so we
stably introduce cas9 into a target cell
of our liking
we then put a set of genes in a pooled
fashion
so that within a single petri dish we
have knockouts for different genes
growing side by side in the same dish
and then we're singling them out and
creating
a single cell rna sequencing data set
i'll speak about
the technicalities of that in a moment
but effectively we're recording the
transcriptome
of any single cell in that in that petri
dish
and we're mapping it back on the guide
rna
that was causing this perturbation and
obviously because we're dealing with
large data sets
we have a need for a computational
analysis which is depicted here on the
right side of the slide
now the difficulty in joining
crispr screens with single cell rna
sequencing
was really to read the guide rna that
was expressed in a given cell
and that's difficult because most single
cell rna sequencing platforms use
beads coupled to oligodt for reverse
transcription of the transmits
of a cell and on the other hand most
crystal screens
use a guide rna expression cassette
in which guide rnas are not
polyadenylated
and so um there was a trick that was
actually necessary to
to sort of make this happen that was
developed by
paul dutlinger in the lab of the
co-founder of alien chris brock
and and the trick was effectively to put
this expression cassette
within the context of a polymerase ii
transcript
so that one could create an indicator
transcript that can be captured
with oligodet coupled beats
so if this is sort of the sequencing
platform
how do we start typically we start these
christmas screens
by designing a set of guides and
for any given for any christmas screen
it's very important
to design the best possible guides
and so we've developed a workflow
in-house
that not only incorporates the sequence
information the local sequence
information
but actually also takes other features
of the
sort of local dna sequence into
consideration
most importantly evolutionary
conservation
but also domains of the proteins that
are encoded by this specific
region and some additional features and
we think it's very important because
again
[Music]
the guides or the effectiveness of the
guides that are used in the screen
ultimately determine the signal to noise
ratio in the
in the experiment so then as a next step
once sort of guides have been designed
in the computer if you like we need to
clone them
and create a lentiviral guide rna
library
and the quality that's typically done
for such a library is shown here
so typically we take either the plasmid
library
or the lentiviral library and we
sequence the guides that are present in
that library
and for a crystal screen
um to to be unbiased it's very important
that we have a very equal distribution
of guides across the entire library and
we feel that the approach that we
developed here
warrants that and warrants that very few
guides
drop out this is a relatively big
library um that we're showing here of 11
000 guides and we're just
losing 21 guides um
or i should say only 21 guides were
represented
at less than 10 percent of the median so
we think we have a very homogeneous way
of cloning these libraries
so what are the quality control steps
that we apply to the cells that we work
with
um now there are two types of workflows
that we typically
look at prior to starting a screen one
is
we take a cas9 expressing cells and we
inactivate
a cell surface marker and we often use
cd81 for that
and so what you can appreciate is that
cells that are untransduced let's say
the parental controls here they have
sort of 98 cd81 signal
but then the moment we're bringing in
the guide which also carries
gfp we're losing cd81
signal sort of greatly the other thing
we do
is we're targeting essential genes
and and that is shown here um so two
examples are two examples are kis-11 and
plk-1 so we're targeting these with
guide rnas
disrupting these essential genes and as
a consequence of that
cells will die in the course of the
experiment
which we're visualizing here because the
cells are pre-labeled
with with gfp and again what you can
nicely appreciate is that
such an experiment allows us to
determine the time point
at which we conduct a christmas screen
and in this particular example we picked
day eight for the for the experiment
now the experiment we focus on and this
has become a little bit of a workhorse
for us is that focused on the signaling
pathway
that is elicited by interfering beta
and the reason is that the signaling
pathway triggers a very defined
transcriptional output which we can
capture with single cell rna sequencing
but also the signaling pathway is one
that has
been studied for at least two decades
and so we know the signaling mediators
in that pathway
very well and so what we did then is
we targeted those mediators that
we know from the literature player role
and we supplemented the library with
additional
um so the friends and family and then um
conducted the crisper screen
and so the workflow against depicted
here we're starting off with a guide rna
design process
that i've explained to you on the
previous slide we're then cloning the
guide rna library in this particular
example we
used three guide rnas per gene a few
non-targeting
guides were also included as reference
points
we then make a pooled lentiviral library
express i'm sorry in fact
a cas9 expressing cell and treated those
cells
with type 1 interferon or left cells
untreated
and then prepped two independent
libraries using conventional
droplet-based
sequencing and when we sequence this
experiment and these experiments get
quite big um an unbiased experiment of
about 10 000
cells is roughly speaking 300 million
reads
and obviously down the line you need to
do a computational analysis
to make sense of that experiment
so how can we visualize that data of
course the data is relatively complex
we're dealing with about 10
000 cells in each experiment that's sort
of the standard unit if you like
and in each of these cells we want to
ideally monitor 20 000 human genes
so these are large matrices that nobody
can really
understand and so there are two ways of
of of sort of visualizing data
one is um the so-called u-map plots that
um most of the single cell rna
sequencing community is quite familiar
with
here every cell is a dot important
uh leave these experiments or these
these types of analyses
are unbiased so they really cluster
cells by their difference in the
transcriptome
and if cells cluster together it means
that transcriptomes are similar to one
another
now for crop seek screens where we
perturb
cells with guides we also
tend to like what we call here the
aggregated view so with the aggregated
view
we're essentially aggregating over all
the cells that have a knockout for a
given gene
and we're analyzing the transcriptomic
changes in that sub-population
if you like and so that allows us to
create more conventional
heat maps which can visualize the
changes going on
as a consequence of the crispr
perturbation
so let's have a first look at the data
this is the experiment i described to
you
the screen where we treated cells or
left them untreated
with type 1 interferon and when we do
this unbiased umap clustering
you can easily appreciate that they have
two big clouds and if we color them
by their origin you can easily
appreciate that the control cells are
very nicely separated
from the interferon stimulated cells and
that means that a lot of the variation
that we observe in the experiment
is attributable to the type 1 interferon
stimulation
if we then ask what are the genes that
are up or down regulated
in control versus interferon beta
we recognize a lot of the genes that um
we are familiar with
um in fact a lot of the genes that are
regulated start with an eye because they
were first described as interferon
regulated or interfering usable genes
um and so that seems to say that we're
sort of uncovering uh or we're sort of
detecting relevant biology here
so then you wonder what are the genes so
what what do the crispr perturbations do
in this particular experiment
and and here we're turning to the
aggregated view that i just described to
you
um so for most of the genes or for most
of the mrnas depicted here on the y-axis
um they're low in unstimulated cells and
they get upregulated in stimulated cells
but then if we perturb um genes on the
x-axis with crispr you can nicely
appreciate
that there is sort of a small set on the
left side that
despite the fact that they were
stimulated they look
very similar to the unstimulated cells
those are positive regulators of the
pathway
and then there is a small set of
negative regulators shown here
towards the right of the heat map
if you compare the little schematic that
i showed you um initially um
to this heat map you will easily
appreciate that
a lot of the genes in fact all of the
genes we uncover here
are the genes that you would like to
uncover
from sort of previous and historic
knowledge
importantly we find the two receptor
subunits if not one and two
the two kinases jack one and take two
and then this transcriptional complex
consisting of set one step two and irf9
so this would suggest that the workflow
is sort of
up and running and it can really
recapitulate sort of known biology
now um in the next part i would like to
um
explain how we can couple
crop seed screens with targeted single
cell sequencing and
if we if we go back to this data set
that i just showed you and we plot all
the 20 000 human genes
um and and we compare the expression
level to the variance observed in the
experiment
you will easily appreciate that most
genes don't um
change much in in in the experiment so
those are the ones
boxed in black and um
those genes are sort of not entirely
ideal because
because they don't provide a great
degree of information
and so what you would ideally like to be
able to do is zoom in on those genes
boxed in orange
which change between cells and which
which does contain all the information
that's relevant
so how can we do that how can we zoom
into those genes this is where
the bd rhapsody machine became very
handy for us
so the beauty rhapsody machine as as
beeland just
explained separate cells in
a microwell based approach
then each well is labeled
with a barcoded bead and so on the
surface of these barcoded beads
reverse transcription happens much like
um
we're used to so from more conventional
approaches but then the real trick here
is the last step is step number three
where
instead of amplifying all the rnas
of the cell we're actually able to
nominate a set of mrnas that we would
like to fish out and we amplify those
using a multiplex pcr and this multiplex
pcr
is illustrated on the next slide again
reverse transcription happens on the
surface of the beads
it transcribes all the rnas of the cell
but then we can nominate a priori the
the mrnas
that we're most interested in and we and
we fish those
out with the pcr base step
now um i would like to give you some
metrics of what sort of typical
experiments um conducted
here at alien look like um so
so i plotted here 15 experiments
and as you can nicely appreciate we
typically load anywhere from
25 to 50 000 cells on one cartridge
this is not what bd recommends bt says
you know typically
they recommend 10 000 cells i believe
per cartridge
but our cells are labeled with
guide rnas and as a consequence of that
we have a very easy way of getting rid
of the multiplets that that we do
observe and that are expected based on
poisson distribution
so that allows us to actually load a lot
more cells
we have a very decent capture rate which
is around 85 percent
and then a very um acceptable multiplet
rate
that is typically anywhere from five to
ten percent
of course as we're increasing the number
of cells we load we're also
increasing the multiple rate
so let's now um go to a crop seek screen
and let's see how the targeted
sequencing technology behaves here we
compared
a whole transcriptome experiment to a
targeted
experiment the targeted sequencing run
was conducted on the bd rhapsody system
we focused on 73 pre-selected mrnas we
look at about 10 000 cells per condition
and we sequence those at about
15 000 reads per cell the whole
transcriptome experiment
was based on droplet sequencing
we did not do any pre-selection
obviously
and again we sequence 10 000 cells but
because it's unbiased we typically have
to sequence at least at 3 thirty
thousand reads per cell
sometimes even at fifty thousand beats
per cell and so the experiment we we
then did
is the exact same experiment i just
described to you so we're looking at the
same guide r in the library we're
looking at
cells stimulated um with interferon beta
and and we're looking at um the outcome
of this
um on the level of the of um the two
platforms
and so with the targeted sequencing the
first thing um i asked
our computational biologist um to do is
let's take those 73 mrnas and plot them
on the x-axis
and let's just ask how many which
fraction of all cells in the experiment
[Music]
contains reads for those 73 mrnas and as
you can nicely appreciate
roughly two-thirds of those mrnas were
really well represented across the great
majority of the cells
now importantly this this representation
is maintained
even if we're sampling the experiment so
we started the experiment and we did the
the actual experiment with 16 000 reads
per cell but we can of course pretend
that the experiment had less reads and
as you nicely appreciate
even with as little as about 3 000 reads
per cell
we get a very nice representation of
those 73 transcripts
across all cells so that's very
important because it would suggest to us
that we can get away with roughly a
tenth of the reeds
that we normally use for unbiased
sequencing
and that means we can squeeze a lot more
into we can squeeze a lot more
information into one
experiment the same thing is sort of
illustrated on this particular slide so
here we're looking at 20 clones
containing non-targeting guides
that's the x axis each of the 20 clones
is sort of
plotted on the x-axis and we're looking
at genes represented
in the targeted panel and as you nicely
appreciate with whole transcriptome
sequencing
the data is very sparse there are a few
transcripts those four on the bottom
here that are present across all cells
but in whole transcriptome sequencing
the great majority is sometimes there
and sometimes not there
and there is nothing you can do about it
now with targeted sequencing
we really overcome this problem and the
great majority of the cells maybe with
the exception of
mx2 expresses the great majority of the
mrnas
we want to sequence so targeted
sequencing really alleviates the
sparsity problem
that we otherwise face in single cell
rna sequencing
so how does this translate into a
functional
effect now obviously the ultimate goal
of the experiment is to see which
knockouts have transcritomic phenotypes
and so we we went back to this
to this heat map that i showed you
earlier
and we compared again whole transcript
from sequencing to targeted sequencing
but this time we adjusted the scale to
the
to the scale that we observed in the
targeted sequencing experiment
and as you can nicely appreciate you
know first
the experiment is qualitatively similar
meaning
the same genes have knockout phenotypes
in both experiments but targeted
sequencing
despite the fact that it's it's read at
a tenth of the number of
reads in this experiment is a lot more
sensitive
so the dynamic range of the experiment
conducted with targeted sequencing as a
workflow is much greater than
with whole transcriptome sequencing
finally we asked how many cells do we
need to get a meaningful phenotype
again this is an important question
because most sequencing workflows
have a fixed number of cells that they
can swallow
and if we can have less cells per
genotype it means our screens can be
enhanced in terms of scale
and so here we looked at a number of
knockout marker pairs that that were
present in the in the screen i just
described to you
and we plot the statistical significance
as observed in the experiment against
the number of cells that we need to to
get to that
um statistical significance and so if
you just
sort of pick out one example you will
appreciate that
whole transcriptome sequencing or let's
say globally whole transcriptome
sequencing curves
are much more shallow than targeted
sequencing curves
and if we just look at this one example
here let's say this markup pair
of mx1 stat 1 we need approximately 75
cells
in the whole transcriptome approach
while we only need
sort of 12 to 15 cells in the targeted
approach
so this would suggest that we cannot
only use
less reads but we can also use less
cells in the experiment
and come out with the same level of
statistical significance
which i think is great news
now in the last sort of five to ten
minutes
i would like to focus on a different
data set
and sort of one of the questions that we
first
had when we started using the media
rhapsody machine is
how sensitive is that machine and how
sensitive is that workflow
um and so in order to address this
question we actually
started from a cancer cell line for
which we had bulk rna sequencing data
and so from that bulk rna sequencing
data set we knew
that we roughly have 12 000 genes
expressed in that cell
and we then distributed these 12 000
genes into different boxes if you like
or different tiers
and picked from the different tiers as
illustrated here 35 genes
per tier and we asked how good is
the targeted single cell sequencing
workflow
at detecting those genes now we already
know that with whole transcriptome
sequencing
especially as you get to the to the to
the sort of tier 1 2 3
it will be quite difficult to see these
genes reliably
but the question is can you bump them up
can you bump them up with a targeted
sequencing
workflow that i just described to you
and this is the data as they came out
so here we're plotting a whole
transcriptome data
against targeted sequencing data and
we're asking what's the percentage
of cells in which the respective gene
was detected
and you can you can nicely appreciate
that if the gene is very abundant like
those pink genes up here then both
workflows would be sort of almost
equally good
at detecting the genes but as we're
going
to less and less abundant genes meaning
to to sort of blue and green
it gets essentially very quickly very
difficult for
whole transcriptome amplification
to actually see those genes in a
significant fraction of the cells
whereas with targeted sequencing
it's actually remarkable that it can
still
pick these mrnas up so i think the only
tier
where targeted sequencing really starts
to struggle a little bit
is the tier 102 which is really very
very close to the
to to sort of um unexpressed or not
expressed
genes in a cell and a similar thing is
illustrated on the on the right side of
the graph
where effectively we're plotting the
same thing
across the seven tiers for whole
transcriptome amplification and targeted
sequencing
so for the abundant genes not a big
difference but especially for those
intermediate and lowly expressed
genes targeted sequencing really makes a
difference and really increases the
coverage
at which we detect those genes
so with that i'm at the end um i would
like to conclude that we're very excited
about
um the targeted single cell rna
sequencing workflow
um it allows us to use a lot more cells
per cartridge i've shown you that we
routinely do 20 to 30
000 cells per cartridge we will need
less weeds per cell we will need less
cells per gene
but the great thing is that it it it
sort of still comes at an improved
dynamic range so we really believe that
this
technology will pave the way towards
genome scale
crop seek screen so genome scale crystal
screens
coupled with a transcriptomic readout
i would like to thank my entire team
here the data presented today were
mainly
from uncle lauriga i'm susan de grove
lukas
is our computational biologist i would
like to also
acknowledge our scientific advisory
board chris bock
and i'm jason moffatt from the
university of toronto
and i would like to finish with a slide
that
um both um vland pabel
and i have put together which sort of
contains a little bit of a guideline for
those
screens so if your screen is a whole
transcriptome screen
and you want to run it with with about
100 genes
you know typically those screens require
100 cells per gene which means you end
up having 10 000 cells in an experiment
you typically need about 50 000 beats
per cell so you need
500 million reads and a good sequencing
platform for that
is the next seek 2000 or the nova seq
s1 on the other hand if you run the
targeted screen
um you might want to look at 500 genes
you know keep in mind this is sort of
already five times the number of genes
i just described for the whole
transcriptome workflow
you should be able to get away with less
cells we think 40 cells could be
realistic
so that 20 000 cells
would be a total if you multiply sort of
500 with 40.
um that would still be a single beady
rhapsody cartridge
5000 um ngs reads per cell is what we
envisage
as meaningful for um targeted
sequencing experiments and so that gets
you to about
100 million reads which is is really one
of the smaller ngs
experiments and the next heck 550 would
be
the right platform for that the mid
output
so i'm not going to go through all the
numbers i
leave you with a slide i'd be happy now
to take
any questions you might have on that
slide or any other slide
i would also like to again thank my
co-speakers
villand and pavel we've had a lot of fun
preparing this
and we hope you enjoyed the webinar so
far
thank you dr kyle hull's dr zajac and dr
berkstromer
burke stummer for your informative
presentations we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
what is the maximum number of sgrnas
you would suggest to add to your multi
multiplex crisper screen
without compromising editing efficiency
that's a good question i would say that
it's
um i mean
let me let me think about the question
um i would say that
um typically
you know just to sort of maybe clarify
typically
we deliver these guide rnas
at a low multiplicity of infection so
that
every cell harbors a single guide rna so
we're not
multiplexing in the sense that we're
throwing all the guides into one cell or
several guys into one cell
um so if that is sort of
the screening paradigm it sort of is
effectively one guideline for cell the
only question is
how many guidelines do you need to get
to a meaningful biological
outcome and here i would say
again it's quite dependent on the
quality
of your guides there there are some
libraries that people believe
they've curated very well and they think
they can get away with as little as two
guide rnas per gene
and you know some of the earlier
libraries that were used in the sort of
early
2015 2016 had up to
10 guides per gene or or sometimes even
more guides
so these days i would say the um
with a well-designed library you should
you should be able to
get away with three or four guides per
gene i hope that answered the question
okay thank you so much we have another
question
is the alien sgrna designer available as
a service
yeah i would say that um um this is
totally something we can
we can discuss typically we don't um do
it as a standalone so we
we um sort of our business model is
effectively to work
with clients where we do end-to-end
projects so we're starting from
sort of taking cells in and then all the
way to the to the
computational analysis but i think you
know we're small and we're
happy to consider sort of any project
okay thank you have another question
how how are the number of detected genes
how do the number of detected genes
vary among different cell types by using
wta
and bd rhapsody system
um that's a good question i would say
that
from from our experience the the main
driver or the main barrier if you like
for both platforms
is the expression level meaning
with the abundant genes they will likely
be
quite easily detectable with both
workflows but
as genes get less and less abundant
the targeted sequencing workflow is
really advantageous because it can
bump up the efficiency at which at which
you can detect
um intermediately or lowly expressed
genes and so um
if the question is sort of how how well
does it work across cell types the
question
should be probably rephrased in how
similar are those cells in terms of
their
transcriptomic profile because that is
sort of the key determinant
um the other the other key determinant
and i didn't spend
much time on that in in the seminar is
that you need to have a good
understanding of where transcription
stops
because you're amplifying with a primer
the three prime end
of a gene and if your three prime
end is very poorly or not at all
annotated
and you're several kilobases away from
where you think that gene ends
it's it's very difficult to pick it up
by a pcr-based approach
so you need to have a good bulk rna
sequencing data set to start with
um to sort of maximize your chances of
picking up
all the genes that you would like to
pick up
okay thank you i have another question
there are a few cases where targeted
sequencing delivers less reads per cell
than
unbiased sequencing what is the reason
for this
well um the reason for this is
that it's still it's still a pcr-based
approach so one of the reasons is that
is the reason that i just alluded to
which is
you may not have annotated your
transcriptional termination signal
correctly
but this you can largely overcome by
performing
rna sequencing prior to designing your
primers
the other possibility is that
that the algorithm your primary design
algorithm fails
we've seen a few cases of that in the
data and you may have noticed that there
were
very few dots of the roughly
sort of 220 genes that we amplified
where whole transcriptome sequencing was
more successful in picking up the gene
than targeted sequencing
there are few such cases but we haven't
encountered many so that there's
definitely i would say less than
less than five percent of all the genes
we target
um seem to be difficult to to sort of
pick up because of
issues with the primary design
all right thank you i'm going to move on
to another question
how long does the workflow on the
rhapsody take
yeah i guess that question can probably
go to me so i'm going to going to answer
this one
remember we want to be nice to ourselves
so we want to be
um we want to to apply the least bias
to ourselves and not give them a lot of
time
to to react by transcriptomic change
um um upon the upon the the experimental
or the workflow conditions so what i'm
saying here is we keep them
in physiological buffer we just let them
sit on the graph on this um
cartridge and settle them down by
gravity this certainly takes some time
so the typical
incubation time on the cartridges is 15
minutes
and then once the cells are settled in
there they are
the beads are added to it which takes
about another let's say three to five
minutes um which adds up to 20 and then
we still do the scanning which also adds
a few minutes to it
so in roughly i would say between lysis
between loading of the cartridge and
lies as we we are looking at
something like 25 to 30 minutes
and then once once the cells are lysed
obviously the mrna the transcriptome is
captured by the beads and nothing
changes anymore
okay i have time for one more question
and i want to remind our audience that
those questions we were unable to answer
today and those that come in during the
on-demand period will be answered
via the email address you provided at
the time of registration
our last question i am interested in
protein analysis and you spoke about
absec
how many proteins can you analyze
simultaneously
yeah i guess um that question i will
take happily take on it
again um absolute yes absent is uh
interrogating the surface markers of the
cells
that are being expressed on the cells
and other than with
inflow cytometry where we um where the
detection goes via rear light so we are
relying relying on the emission spectrum
of the of the dye and hence we are sort
of limited in terms of
um mixing too many dyes to each other
with with each other because the
emission spectra at some point will
overlap and hamper the analysis
this is not the case when you design uh
when you when you're able to couple
oligonucleotides to your antibodies and
you can design them bioinformatically
before you do so
so long answer short we
support a panels as complex as 100
blacks
and i do know of customers who do more
than that
which at the moment is not officially
supported but
we know it works
well thank you again uh dr kyle hulse dr
zajac and dr burke summer do you have
any final comments for our audience
yeah um oh go ahead
i i just want to re-emphasize that i
think this
is at my point of view um the targeted
sequencing workflow on the video
rhapsody is really
for us has become a game changer because
it really allows
um sort of screens at a different level
you know we've done hundred thousand
cells in one day last week
and um um i really think that
um um this will make a difference and
will
will sort of um change the way we we
conduct these experiments
and i just wanted to mention that it's
been fantastic to work with
all of you so thank you very much and i
also wanted to encourage all the
all the listeners please don't hesitate
to get in touch with any of us
in case you have any questions about
single cell sequencing
of sequencing or the crop seek method
we're more than happy to
to assist yeah and a few final words
from myself
as well before they say thing thanks to
all of you
um working for bd biosciences
um with with such an innovation uh
innovative um surrounding and and
so partnering with with people like like
gentlemen like like
pavel here is is really great fun and um
we as spd we really want to support
the biology and advanced biology by
bringing these innovative tools to
market and as
i'm very happy to see the use cases that
are coming out of this
as we have just it has has just been
demonstrated by gretchen
thanks a lot
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
and once again questions we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information that you provided
at the time of registration we would
like to once again thank our speakers
for their time today and for their
important research we would also like to
thank
lab roots and our sponsors illumina and
bd biosciences for underwriting today's
educational webcast
you can visit the webinar on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
that's all for now until next time
goodbye